Tức nhận phản ánh nhiều thi sinh thân khó với đề tóan, tiếng ánh cuộc ki tý tốt nghiệp Trung Hoặc Phổ thông năm 2020,
phó cuộc trường cuộc quan lý chất lượng, bộ giáo dục và đào tạo nguyễn ngọt hà cho biết,
công tác đề thi năm nay có nhiều đề mới, câu chút, định giảm đề thi thay đổi hoàn toàn xói năm trước,
tính chất mới này có thể với bữa ngỡ cho thi sinh.
Bới những thi sinh có chuẩn bị kỹ lưỡng trong quá trình học và ông tập thi sẽ đáp ứng yêu cầu của đề thi tốt hơn những thi sinh khác.
Tức trong năm học, bộ giáo dục và đào tạo đã ban hành câu chút, định giảm của đề thi và công bố đề tham thảo từ tháng 2 năm 2020.
Bới mục đích xuống học sinh quen với câu chút, định giảm đề có định hưởng ôn tập.
Bán chỉ đạo các quốc gia đã có sự quan chết trước khi công tác làm định giảm,
bới quan điểm chỉ đạo năm nay là năm đầu đổi mới nề không thay đổi trạng thái đột một trong đó có cả vấn đề độ họ của đề thi.
Bộ giáo dục và đào tạo đã tổ chức thử nghiệp địa trên dễ dọc ở cả 8 miền là đề đánh giả hành án tích ứng của các thi sinh nhằm điều trình độ họ trong công tác làm địa.
Các số lựa trong công tác thử nghiệp địa thi, phô điểm đã được cho đổi kỹ ở các tổ làm địa và khi làm địa cũng yêu cầu phải bám sát để tham khảo đã công bố.
Bộ vi nhận phần ánh về độ họ của địa và sế có sự xem sét, đánh giả của thi khi công tác chấm thi hoàn thiệt.